thank you
our next guest from the mothership has
quickly risen to the top of NFL analysts
we take absolutely no cheap shots
against him when he's dishing knowledge
on NFL live we never want the show to
end he's totally in the zone day in and
day out he takes care of everything he's
never out of bounds he's the safety
blanket for ESPN's NFL coverage say
hello to Dan orlovsky yeah
lovely intro yeah thank you Daniel we've
already done this but what's up what's
up I don't know if I should say what's
up after that but wait you didn't take
shots did you did you read anything into
that intro that we just gave you there
so a couple things okay one you said you
never take any shots that's accurate you
took three I counted them okay I'm gonna
put my headphones on it could be warm
since you don't have a jacket here I'm
totally warm the second thing is when
you guys put up the picture of everybody
that's a guest today yeah one of the
things that stood out to me is everybody
I think it's Cranston
um Peter King Debo and Eisen Eisen
everybody's like a face forward shot and
you guys picked a shot of me turned to
the side I think it's to hide the the
rest of my ears
so another say look at everyone's face
on but me
I don't think that uh we did that on
purpose that looks like a glamor shot
yeah it's like filmed five years ago
okay
uh by the way NFL live Old Town
Scottsdale for Super Bowl week beginning
today through Friday for Eastern uh Dan
will be there with Laura Rutledge Mina
kimes Marcus Spears and Ryan Clark how's
morale great
ready to go where's the drama in the
Super Bowl
um I think the can Patrick Mahomes like
go to three and four years and only have
one I think that's probably a big
conversation
um you know Jalen and and the shoulder
he has not played well since at least as
a thrower since the injury and so that
that's a big part of is he gonna re kind
of rebound from the injury
um you know I think Jeffrey Laurie put
the bed a little bit of this but I had
quietly been thinking you know Philly's
been to the Super Bowl twice in the last
I think six seasons right 17 and then
this year so five or six seasons uh both
times with the rookie quarterback deal
and I was always like sitting there
wondering do they just believe that that
is the blueprint like no no matter who
the quarterback is they're going to
draft one they're going to move on from
the expensive one and then continue to
try to have the best roster in football
and then Jeffrey Laurie the other night
kind of said and he doesn't need to do
anything to prove himself anymore he's
exactly what they're looking for so uh
but that was a little bit of a a
question mark that I had moving forward
and it feels like we've all focused on
mahomes's injury and not Jalen hurts he
has not thrown well since that Chicago
game he hasn't regular season week 18
when he had to play didn't play well
didn't throw it well he didn't throw a
well against the um Giants he did not
throw it away against the San Francisco
49ers and I don't think like just this
two-week stretch is automatically going
to make it that much better so that's
like the most concerning thing that I
would have about the whole Super Bowl
well explain that injury is he going to
need surgery uh some guys need it yeah I
think some guys need it I would say this
like I I'm not a doctor obviously it
took 17 years to graduate from college
um but I think like the thing that
stands out with Jalen over the past four
or five games since the injury in
comparison to before is the control of
the football or lack thereof I think
that's where he made his greatest growth
this year was like he could control the
football the tempo of the ball that he
wanted the placement of the ball that he
wanted How firm it had to be you know
the the Deep ball was such a great
growth for his and the control of that
has has really slipped over the past
again like six weeks since that injury
and I think if you if you took like the
the really deep dive into the game if
you're Steve Spagnola the defense
coordinator for the Chiefs they're going
to sit there and go well you have to
prove it to me I'm not going to let you
guys run the football at least they're
going to try to do that and they're
going to play sticky man coverage and be
physical at the line and say Jalen we're
going to see what the shoulder feels
like and I think that the lack of
control
um that has kind of been showing over
the last six weeks is a big deal I
really do I just think that it's not
necessarily like the pain it's do you
feel completely free like do you just
have games as a quarterback where you
warm up and you're like I'm throwing it
today like there's nothing I cannot do
with this football and I just don't see
that right now from Jalen you hear
pictures a lot and here we are it's
appropriate to ask this uh at Scottsdale
Stadium they'll have it when they're
warming up yeah and then they go to the
end of the game and they don't have it
or vice versa yeah do quarterbacks have
similar uh you know games where they're
like man I'm killing it in warm-ups and
then you get to the game and you're like
what the hell where'd that go it's like
me on a driving range yeah I'm great on
the Range yeah let me get on the course
I'm like okay yeah
um yeah I think quarterbacks have that
because there's other variables attached
too you know like you get hit early on
in the game and that hit lingers for the
whole game that could be part of it
um yeah I think you got you you have
that as a quarterback where sometimes
you feel great you know throwing the
football though is such a
um like a individual thing you know
pitching I I don't never played like
High Level Baseball so I don't know how
much that impacts your mind but when
you're a quarterback and you feel like
you could throw it unless you're taking
a shot early on in the game that really
doesn't go away
I I found an interesting quote whereas
uh Tom Brady's dad said Tom got tired of
getting hit yeah well obviously I would
think nobody likes getting hit unless
maybe Josh Allen Josh Allen likes
getting hit rockles Burger did he like
getting hit I think a lot of
quarterbacks like getting hit if the end
result is what they wanted like there
was no better feeling as a quarterback
than when you would take a huge shot and
you look up and the ball was complete
because that was devastating to a
defense right
um I think as you got older you got less
and less appreciative of the shots and
of the hits so but there's some
quarterbacks that embrace it I sit with
college coaches all the time and we you
know one of the questions we'll ask
these guys when it comes to younger
quarterbacks he's like how do you find
ways to get them in rhythm in the game
and eighty percent of the time they're
like well we want to run them early to
get him hit so they can settle into the
game I think like the younger generation
of quarterbacks is embracing the
physicality of the position more than
guys of the past assess the quarterbacks
in this year draft
I think the the four kids that are
probably going to be talked about a
bunch in the first round so Bryce young
to me is like Steph Curry everything is
so slow for him but he plays so fast
I love him I love his game I think he's
one of those players you sit there and
go don't overthink it much but we will
he is not big and that is putting it
lightly I mean he is once you meet him
in person it takes you back a little bit
because you if you just contrast him to
the Stars the young stars in the league
right now you go Josh Allen Patrick
Mahomes Justin Herbert
um Burrows six five Joe burrow even
Jalen Jalen's thick uh Bryce isn't he's
slight he's he's not tall and he's
slight his shoulders are slight so I
think that's easy to uh like no two is
probably 15 20 pounds heavier easily
like way thicker and we see what's
happening to him in the NFL and Dan I
was gonna like we started to talk about
this a little bit we're saving it for a
little bit of the draft but the
quarterbacks that have kind of become
the or we've seen the acceptance of
drafting smaller sized quarterbacks in
the past couple years
you can make the case that none of them
have really panned out here you know out
Kyler question marks and injured Baker's
been all over the place even though he's
a little bit thicker
um and I think two of because of the
injuries is part of that conversation as
well so but Bryce is special he's a
special talent but he's he's not big CJ
Stroud I'm a huge fan of I think he
thinks the game the best he can throw it
he's the best pure thrower I think he as
a passer just as a pastor he's he's an
upgrade athletically but as a pastor he
reminds me of golf just very natural
very fluid thrower Levis is going to be
the guy that people will sit here and
say he's the number one pick or he's not
a first round Talent just a crazy
physical Talent he can absolutely whip
the ball
um tough dude
there's going to be question marks of
how well he can see the field how well
he thinks how well he processes how come
his numbers weren't better you'll hear
that is he going to be Zach Wilson or is
he going to be Josh Allen that's
probably going to be the the comp that
you'll sit there and kind of point to
and then
um Anthony Richardson is a freak I mean
he's a I called some of his freshman
year games at Florida and then I called
his first game this year against Utah he
is an absolute Superstar Talent if you
are an organization that like wants to
take a guy and you are a hundred percent
committed to sitting for two years and
your coach and general manager on on the
hot seat and I know that's a little bit
of a rarity in the NFL you take him he's
a tremendous Talent we're talking to Dan
orlonsky of the mothership NFL live
starting today through Friday at 4
Eastern uh Dan also calling the Super
Bowl in uh New Zealand and Australia I
thought it was me and Greg together
Olsen no no no no no sorry sorry about
that you're down on the list yeah
uh do you have an Australian accent
I've done that once we usually for NFL
live yeah you probably don't want to do
that yeah we uh for NFL live we we have
to like tape a hit for
um Australia usually and at one time
like I was like I'll do an Australian
accent and say something they were like
no no no no no
yeah so what advice would you give Tom
Brady going into Broadcasting
um I think that one your opinion is
always wrong
um and it should be you know like we
live in this world where like people get
so caught up on opinion and Analysis
your opinion should be wrong like when
you have an opinion as long as you
justify your opinion you want people to
disagree with your opinion that that's
part of this job you should strive to
have your analysis be accurate and I
think that's one of the things that I
would tell Tom you know like you're
gonna be wrong what's the difference of
your opinion and your analysis because
your analysis should form your opinion I
think analysis is a little bit more
scientific you know like when I watch
tape I can make the analysis on tape
that the Philadelphia's Philadelphia
Eagles defense struggles at moments to
handle motion and Crossing routes that's
analysis and I can prove to you that
that analysis is accurate
um I could have the opinion that
um
you know Joe Montana doesn't make it
into my top five what the hell is wrong
with you
that's that's an opinion
to go along with something like that
because it if if it's a standalone
opinion yeah I'm dying to know what the
analysis is that would be attached to
that I think there's two things I mean
if we want to rehash the top five
quarterback conversation this is going
to follow you the rest of your career so
uh I think that I mean that's not an
opinion that's analysis it means not top
20 in yards or touchstones that has to
matter somewhat and then everyone goes
to the Super Bowl record respectfully as
they should okay the defense gave up 15
points per game in those four Super
Bowls
okay
Paulie bring out Joe Montana
the conversation also that is my opinion
thinking well Mourinho was probably
better
I could put Aikman into that
conversation I could put Drew Brees into
that conversation we can't just sit
there and say well he's top five because
he he was went to four Super Bowls you
can't do that like that's okay you're so
much more attached to the game you have
to win again that's an opinion you have
to win a Super Bowl Tom Brady then
Patrick okay
and then
um
probably Elway okay Payton
Montana
okay so you made your top five in
winning the most important game
no I didn't it made six
right oh then Merino yeah I'm Reno and
now we're in the conversation I'm not
this isn't a dump on Joe Montana thing
for me but it appears to be
but it's not I but that's why you can't
if you had a time if you had him on NFL
live yeah would you say I'd ask him
about Skechers would you ask him about
what would you say hey I just want to
let you know I think you're maybe in the
top 20 in quarterbacks yeah and he would
probably look at me laugh and be like
cool now he might not matter I mean he
might not care about it I would imagine
Joe Montana does not care that I don't
have him in the top five I mean right I
mean my bigger things going on he might
say you're not even the fifth best
quarterback in UConn history
who are the top five then
well nobody can name five good
quarterbacks at UConn
uh then I would win that argument that I
would win that argument you're a guy who
manipulated your 40-yard dash time
like I don't know if I can trust you
when it comes to you know many that's
many years ago Dan I'm not that same
person oh you're not I'm a changed man I
respect I haven't changed I respected
that that and you wonder what you
wouldn't be sitting here I told my
friend I told uh we were at a friend's
house the other and I would not be
sitting here no no I told that story
again to a friend's house the other
night so
my kids are my I have sons who are 11
years old I have triplets under 11 and
then I have a daughter who's seven and
we live in Connecticut and listen I'm
not like shoot your dreams down type
person at all I'm actually the complete
opposite but my kids play youth sports
right and I was like at my daughter's
basketball game two weeks ago and I met
my son's lacrosse games all the time and
whatnot and hearing parents talk about
their kids the NFL the NBA majorly we're
gonna have to form new leagues there's
not gonna be enough professional sport
leagues for all the kids that are going
to become professional sports players
and so I was trying to like you know
oftentimes people in town or parents in
town ask me like what should I do with
my kid you know when do I need to start
their private training I'm like dude
they're nine and they can barely wipe
themselves guys so like we don't
um and so I was telling that story the
other night because everyone was like do
you out of the all the kids the friends
groups who do you think are the kids who
can go play professional athletes oh my
God that's it guys this is how I made it
this is how I actually made the
professional sports so
um now once again Scouts were coming and
then you it was Ed So Randy Edsel you
wanted to come to watch her practice and
you moved the cones on the 40-yard dash
yeah because I knew of Uconn I had not
had any offers then and I knew that if
UConn didn't offer me no one was going
to go so you know we had two cones
starting finish and I was running that
like five eight maybe at that time and I
knew like if I did not get a offer from
UConn I wouldn't buy anybody and he
showed up and my dad went to go see him
so I kicked the final cone up like four
or five yards
when I ran it in that moment it was four
eight oh realistically it was like
and then I went to Camp that summer and
I ran like five or six yeah
yeah I wasn't I wasn't an athlete or
athletic did did Coach look at his watch
and like wait I'll never forget he
looked at me arms up like the Emoji he
went arms up and I responded back with
my hamstring
I knew what I was doing I was the kid
who went to the mailbox and took the
report card and scribbled yeah changed
the grade yeah and cheated my way
through like adolescence uh the biggest
off-season story is going to be what
great question
um
I'm not going to say Rogers
um what the Jets do at quarterback I
think is is probably the biggest
off-season conversation I think the Jets
are a legit legit like divisional round
playoff team you can make the case AFC
Championship caliber defense and if
they're healthy up front
I think the Jets can play with anyone I
really do but who should go there
that's the toughest part of this
conversation Dan because they have to
take a big swing I mean it's a winner
winner go home type of thing for Robert
Sala and Joe Douglas the head coach and
general manager so you sit there and go
well if it's not Rogers well who's it
going to be
because they have four options it's go
ahead with Zach Wilson I don't think
that's the thing sign Aaron Rodgers go
find a way to get Rogers but the only
way you go get Rogers is if like she
commits to being around in March April
May they got a young team you know and
you like not only his leadership but
just the energy like the the energy has
to be around the organization so those
guys really get ready for the fall
um it's it's
draft another rookie again I don't think
that's gonna happen or Jimmy Garoppolo
Derek Carr and I think that listen I'm a
I'm a big Derek Carr guy
but you have to figure out before you
try to trade indoor sign for him it's
not do you think he could play good it's
do you think he can handle the burden
and the expectations of what next season
is for the Jets in New York that's a big
deal like that's in that not everyone
can handle that
I want to thank you for uh all the
contributions during the season uh ESPN
ESPN PR department poor you know PR
department fritzy is is so annoying they
don't I don't mean to be a pain in the
neck but fritzy thinks that the ESPN
talenters are supposed to be on our show
and that's part of the problem after all
those years with ESPN I thought you
don't work there anymore I don't neither
one of us do no we don't no but that's
great we don't get paid to come on the
show no way no I think there's some
parting gifts or something The Dan
Patrick board game or something I got a
sandwich I got the slider over there
that's why I looked incredible oh it's
great you should get it and I'll give
you I'll give you two if you want you
can take one back to big swagoo he eats
enough he don't need more food he does
the intermittent fasting so he's not
going to eat till like two or something
today all right
um by the way if you're watching on
peacock we're going to see if Dan will
crank up that uh that arm
you want to see if you guys said Brady
Quinn almost threw it to the infield
yeah yeah he was probably 40 feet short
Huck
I mean you should have a lot of mileage
still there I don't know my shirt might
be too there's nothing you could do
moving cones today so you can't
manipulate this but you know let's let
America see that arm you know we didn't
get to see it enough in the NFL it
wasn't good enough Brady Quinn took his
shirt off by the way too
of course he did yeah uh Dan orlovsky of
the mother that's a before after photo
then you you're like olive oil and he's
Popeye uh Monday through Friday you can
see NFL live but uh this week today
through Friday for Eastern you can catch
Dano with Laura Rutledge medikines
Marcus Spears Ryan Clark we're back with
our play of the day right after this